the question that we have before us is
when do the divisions between us and
them
when is that productive when is that
something that really helps our
societies and in what cases does it
become really problematic and how can we
overcome those problems and maybe
reconfigure the we and them or at least
see them not in an antagonistic way or a
threatening way but in a way that's
complementary or that we can live in
coexistence that historically the ways
in which states and governments and
societies have tried to construct these
feelings of trust and and
and solidarity is by defining out groups
so we build in group solidarity by
distinguishing ourselves as different
from and better than others and in
today's world that strategy is just it's
dangerous and it's it's self-defeating
it as a matter of public policy of
concerned citizens of people of the
world we want to understand how we can
build a more inclusive and just society
what see far allows and I think this is
unique really to see far is it allows a
group of people who share interests to
spend some time together to figure out
how to talk to each other how to draw
links with each other and then be able
to design some more specific
collaborative research projects if we
can better understand how to mitigate
the negative consequences of seeing
someone as an other potentially blur the
boundaries between groups maybe
sometimes erase those boundaries or
recognize that people are different but
that we can still work together in
collective projects to increase the
rights and resources that everybody has
I think will make our world a better
place
[Music]
you